it's not been a question for 100 years
not since 1923 when it took nine rounds
of voting to elect Frederick Gillett as
Speaker of the House of Representatives
please raise your right every time since
it's been decided on the first vote but
2023 is possibly going to be very
different the presumptive speaker Kevin
McCarthy has been lobbying his fellow
Republicans since the midterm election
but he still seems short of votes
hey we'll go have a good day tomorrow
there will be 222 Republicans sworn in
McCarthy needs 218 of them to vote for
him to become speaker five on the far
right have already said they will never
vote for him so McCarthy has made some
concessions promising to change the
rules so just five Representatives can
call for a vote to remove him from
leadership right now it would take a
majority of Republicans
he's also pledged to create committees
to investigate the justice department
over its investigation of former
president Donald Trump and a committee
focused on competing with China but
seven additional Republicans released a
letter saying it's still not enough once
Republicans do elect the speaker it
seems unlikely they'll be able to pass
significant legislation because
Democrats control the Senate and the
white house but they can do though is
try to obstruct President Joe Biden's
agenda and launch investigations I think
they are fine with being able to do more
oversight and want you know the White
House to answer questions about
Afghanistan
um want to talk about
coronavirus where did it come from did
the government have anything to do with
it much of the agenda will depend on who
is handed the Gap
as of now no one seems sure that it will
be Kevin McCarthy Patty culhane Al
Jazeera Washington